hello and welcome to this video playing
marzipan cat well it's been a while
since I played the marzipan kids really
a while but I've got a couple of games
four out of eight fifty percent so don't
think there's any there is additional
information no it's an old account a six
that's a pretty decent line it looks a
little bit exotic but it's fairly okay
like gets this extended here keto then
our legal c5 and I don't know exactly
how this is played I think why place
with 93 and going to be six so something
like that okay I didn't expect that to
happen but why not
I thought after a future deform c5 could
could become weak we'll see what happens
[Music]
yeah device blipping very Airy normal
him and after yeah black has to take
almost so what's now the captures they
they they they make sense the both make
sense even Bishop takes there's some
point to that and this is the most
natural move down let's play it the cool
side is potentially weak
it's interesting it's an interesting way
to try if I take like love tea with the
Queen it's still a little bit better for
me okay actually f3 threatening Knight
will be six in this position yes and now
if I go before where do you go yep
creation Queen e2 and Roxy one
maybe that's still okay for him is still
okay for black I'm a little bit better
but not much
why does that work
so 96 this Knight f3 or was the point
96 not f3 Knight f8 I don't think so
you know just a big pawn Knight f3 9f8
this I don't think that is any trickery
that would work so it is really just a
pawn yeah so maybe this is a good square
covering all done yeah I was I was
hoping actually for this move so I can
put the bishop here covering be 65 and
so on that looks quite good my next move
would be rook c4 unless he does
something extraordinary
to try to double on the C file okay so
here I can also put something on the
default threat is now Queen c-47 Oh
doesn't check doesn't do anything about
it it should be pretty awful now oh
that's still possible that's true
it's about the only play of the move
Queen to e2 ha
um if I go look to see four 7s hanging
so I mean the night cannot move because
it 7s hanging is what I'm trying to say
not very successfully and I'm
threatening all t5 OOP t5
yeah but that's a piece right - mm-hm I
basically not to take it actually Oh is
there a reason to them I can take it
black lines yeah net 95 was was a
blunder 95 before that I'm just a bit
more comfortable but nothing nothing
much okay so let's have a look and
before and I was surprised by that move
I think it should help me a little bit
as the Queen side is potentially week I
was expecting Queen b6 mostly it's kind
of kind of normal this position so this
is this and here maybe I can improve
galaxy one there's so many better young
now it makes anything because it is
quite difficult to suggest you move for
black probably taking alright this is
just a met better version over the game
yeah now after the chicken this no no no
I'm just quick I if he does the same
thing I had a text
that's excellent yeah books you wanted
stronger this is yet helping images of
the gem in this position it's just
slightly rare what the engine says yeah
something we knew make you edit blunders
something he has no trickery I like this
I can just take the book it's basically
basically end of game Kenny he's
completely tied down what if is a big
threat so yeah yeah and that's it
after queen bee aid and just take this
and turn there's not much there
my king is completely save and queen
will be traded yeah okay guys thanks for
watching